good citizens of the reject Nation I am
koi genre and I am very excited for this
very trailer I have waited all year
we're two weeks after the end of the
year and it's finally here how you doing
John I I am I am excited too sir and I'm
happy to be here with you ready for
across the spider verse it's on now Greg
is not here because he is across the
country about to be wed we don't leave
till tomorrow but that means this is
also likely our last trailer reaction of
the year because you know betrothal but
what a perfect one it's time to get
after it please leave a like very
important hit that subscribe Bell leave
a comment let us know your favorite part
of the trailer spoiler alert is going to
be Miguel O'Hara Oscar Isaac about to
own very excited let's get into it
I'm still shocking excited dude no dude
I can hear you being quiet mom
oh I am
hope I didn't ice your game man no one
my age says those words in that order
it's just hard to see my little man not
be my little boy all the time
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
uh-huh
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to belong to the world and do
great big things
not bad kid I like the new suit and what
I worry about most
that's gorgeous
shoes they won't look out for you like
us
I love the mood yeah
want to get out of here every texture
where do you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
make sure you never oh cool
oh my God
The Citadel spiders
he never doubts that he's loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't
you gotta promise miles
I promise
dang
oh
really yeah
aggressive lines in Spider-Man 299 is
perfect that is like it's such an
overwhelming trailer I was like silent
it was just I know I I feel like we we I
need to watch it there was so much going
on play it back that was incredible yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah just like off the
bat the combination of both mood and
emotion but with all the you know
spider-verse Madness that you want like
I I love that they kind of they took me
off guard with how they approached the
mood of this trailer it was solemn it
almost felt like uh like a legacy
trailer for a movie like five into a
franchise I don't know when you're like
we're gonna look back at some times
we've had like it was a very heavy
trailer yeah it feels like like at the
point later on in a franchise where
you're like no no we got to make this
like really emotional and heavy because
our characters are getting mature by
this point which isn't like unfitting
for you know a coming-of-age journey as
miles is still on but and just the the
shot they've chosen like I love that
this is some Redemption for Spider-Man
losing Gwen in life like so the
Multiverse get spider going with miles
but like that Spider-Man Gwen connection
is so beautiful always but specifically
theirs like this is such a great
rom-composter yeah oh that's a good
point you know what I mean like it's so
special for this character set I love
his new costume uh I think the blend of
I mean we saw at least five animation
Styles not to mention all the Spider-Man
had their own animation style like their
own Universe was formatted to them
seemingly first of all I feel like we
definitely saw the Spider-Man from the
video game voiced by Yuri and then I
think I saw like police cop uh which is
a voice thing I think Yuri did for the
Spider-Man game as well so you're gonna
have like Easter egg on Easter egg
within the game I think I saw Spider-Man
Unlimited the Animated Series
um pretty sure I saw spider monkey in a
later frame on the top left I thought I
saw a spider with a tail I think it's
spider monkey
spider monkey very likely good sir nor
do I say man spider and there was a man
spider in there he's a man spider
there's a man supposed at least not not
maybe all the same colors there was
definitely a Spider-Man with six to
eight arms and then like a werewolfy
spider uh and then I saw I do believe a
Spider-Man uh like superior Spider-Man
suit which mirrors the Scarlet Spider uh
talking to the Spider-Man from the video
game uh I hope that's your it's got to
be Yuri uh and we got Bag Man bag man I
got my Funko Pop back man huge moment
okay so we can break down those things
forever but uh certain key moments jump
out we talked about tone but feelings
yeah I mean this this caught me off
guard in a lot of different ways again
like we said the somber tone him talking
to his mom which I thought was a great
great wrap around like I really like
that they chose to go with a lot of
silence and then yeah going through this
like Nexus web like part of me was
expecting like oh we're gonna go
Multiverse hopping in a trailer like
this but even the teaser trailer didn't
quite do that either it more focused in
on him and Gwen this one focuses in on
him and his mom and so I love that
spider like what made the first movie so
great is that it is magnificently
personal and it's a real character story
but it has all this imagination and all
this craziness and all these worlds and
spider folk and all sorts of stuff and
so like that is present here but I like
that they are using some restraint with
all the places we could go and whom we
might see we're we're seeing this like
web of Spider-Man and at all you know
and that's kind of expansive enough
because through that I can feel the
promise of all the other places we might
end up and so I like that they keep a
good amount of surprise in the
anticipation based off this but are also
giving you a ton to look forward to in
all these different iterations of the
character yeah so I'm I'm really uh
thrilled and enthralled by the sort of
left of center approach they took with
this and I can't wait to see what the
movie delivers on because now I'm not
only hyped first Spider-Man 2099 and all
this hijinks but also like to see miles
continue growing as a character dude
this is not out till May and they just
gave us this so but I think those are
really smart to use about a minute of
footage in a two and a half minute
trailer from the last film so we are
given a ton of new data but not a lot of
new footage because you can look at this
and see spider monkey you can see
Spider-Man Unlimited from the Animated
Series surprise like there's so many
things they can do we're gonna bring in
other worlds other multiverses other
universe that already established but we
don't know a lot and that's great
because this is far enough out I love
that we don't get a lot of Spider-Man
2099 talking I'm very excited for Oscar
Isaac's betrayal he's one of my favorite
Spider-Man I'm so shocking excited but I
don't want to have too much too soon I
also love the vulture being in that very
uh almost Galileo Illustrated like you
know the old sketch style looks like
it's drawn a piece of parchment whatever
is that yeah I can't wait for that world
because we've seen steampunk but we
haven't seen that and that's another
element uh and if you look at a few of
the the big Nexus you were describing it
as
um there's a lot of that like one two
animation where it's two frames and the
characters are moving at every other
frame yeah so like they're like as if
they're drawn on twos yeah so I think
that's really interesting I'm wondering
if that Nexus what what the rules of
that world are because it's almost like
their suits are moving independent of
them and then the background moving
independent of them so I wonder if you
go through and it's like slowed down if
if background's moving they're moving
costumes moving like what that element
is in the animation because this is some
of the most staggering like everything I
wanted out of this and I do think you're
right I think they're gonna have this
Nexus and then in the third movie it's
gonna be more the Multiverse hopping
because the last one you have to build
to something yeah and then I you know
with them bringing in animated movies as
well as uh sorry animated shows as well
as the video game I could see this tying
into the Madame Web movie and this being
I was gonna make a joke about that but I
mean maybe because it is and and you
know a spider verse it wouldn't
absolutely not make sense or anything
like that you know and Jessica Drew in
this I'm so excited to see Jessica Drew
uh she's fighting vulture Jessica Drew
is one of my favorite characters if you
haven't read the arc where she's like a
single mom raping a kid porcupine great
stuff very slept on character I think
she's gonna be the the surprise of this
movie like Spider-Man Noir was maybe
she'll join the crew because I you know
you got Gwen and uh Jake Johnson
Spider-Man in 2099 seemingly all
together for this adventure maybe
they'll pull her in yeah and that pink
robe it's gonna be a lot of people on
Halloween wearing a pink robe as opposed
to sweatpants Jake B Johnson always the
trendsetter Peter B Parker Jake Johnson
always a Vibe always correct uh what did
you guys think of this trailer I am
enamored I'm in love I am enthralled I
am so about it I am very excited too as
soon as we hit cut watch this frame by
frame if that was fighter monkey all
right Yuri I hope you're in this I love
you let's get after it leave a comment
leave a like share stuff much love
spider first
Gene the Jeter if there's anybody at
this patreon page who would be the most
fitting to travel across a Multiverse
finding and recruiting all of his
different iterations it would it would
easily be you Gene I mean you already
occupied so many creative spaces you are
a loving and loyal guy but you also get
a sense of adventure you know you're
always out photographing beautiful
people and taking on different kinds of
challenges with your creative expression
and that's the kind of Multiverse I want
to live in you have been a supporter of
this patreon page of this channel for so
long and I just can't thank you enough
especially you know with all of the
craziness that we've dealt with behind
the scenes over the years you have been
a constant you've been one of those
people especially patreon especially
with all the wackiness that YouTube can
throw your way patreon has been such a
wonderful Saving Grace and it's people
like you
and koi I'll let you talk to Gene in a
second because people like you who
really warm our hearts and make us feel
loved and supported so thank you buddy
appreciate you very much might I say yes
sir great superhero name Gene Jeter
alliteration okay Peter Parkers you know
your Jay Jonah Jamesons your Miles
Morales Jean Jeter right there in the
spider-verse Well Done parents of Gene
Jeter meant to be buddy happy Christmas